أريد أن أطرح عليك سؤالاً آخر
يثيره بعض حلفائك العرب، كما تعلم، لأنهم
قلقون للغاية بشأن النزوح الجماعي الذي
يتم تشجيعه من غزة ليس فقط إلى
الجنوب ولكن أيضًا إلى مصر كما نعلم أن
الحدود  مغلق في الوقت الحالي، لكن
العديد من الأشخاص في غزة يخشون أنهم إذا
غادروا فلن يتمكنوا من
العودة مرة أخرى، وسؤالي لك
هو هل سيعطي رئيس الوزراء هؤلاء
الأشخاص اتفاقًا مكتوبًا بأنهم
سيتمكنون من العودة إلى ديارهم؟  المنازل
جيدًا، لا أعتقد أننا وصلنا إلى هذه المرحلة
بعد بالطبع نحن نناقش الأمور
مع المصريين أه أه ولكن وأنا
أتفهم حقيقة أن الأشخاص الذين
فروا من فلوريدا الذين يغمرون منازلهم يخشون
ألا يتم ذلك  قادر على العودة ولكن
هذا جزء من الحرب وهذه حرب
أذكركم بها مرة أخرى ولن
أتعب من تذكيرها مرارًا وتكرارًا
هذه حرب فُرضت
علينا ولم نفعلها  لقد بدأنا الأمر ولم
نرغب في حدوث ذلك، لقد دفعنا
الثمن الباهظ والآن ما نحاول القيام به هو
الدفاع عن شعبنا الذي التقيت به
بالأمس، الأشخاص الذين تم إجلاؤهم
من منطقة ريكي بوتس التي أعتقد
أنك زرتها مرة واحدة و  التقيت بفتاة تبلغ من العمر 13 عامًا
ووصفت لي كيف
قُتلت صديقتها المفضلة أمام
عينيها، ويجب أن أعدها بأن هذا
لن يحدث مرة أخرى أبدًا، وهذا ما
نفعله الآن، لذا نعم
سيكون هناك  بؤس نتيجة لهذا ومرة
أخرى هذا السؤال حول هذا
البؤس يجب أه أن يستهدف حماس
وليس
علينا ماذا عن المخاوف من حرب أوسع
قالت إيران أنتم تعلمون أنها لن تقف
مكتوفة الأيدي قال الرئيس الإيراني
والحديث مع الرئيس الفرنسي إذا كانت
إسرائيل تسعى لتعويض
فشلها بمواصلة هذه الجرائم فإن
أبعاد التطورات ستتسع
لا أدري كيف تقرأ ذلك وهل
تصدق وهل
حكومتك ومخابراتك تصدقان أن
هناك تدخيناً؟  البندقية التي
خططت لها إيران بالفعل ساعدت في التخطيط لها
جيدًا أولاً وقبل كل شيء، إذا جاز لي أن أقتبس من
الرئيس بايدن أه إذا كانوا يريدون إذا كانوا
يفكرون في الأمر، فلا أعني
نعم لقد فاجأنا أه في
الجنوب الإسرائيلي بالقرب من غزة  ولكننا لن
نتفاجأ مرة أخرى عندما لا
نتفاجأ الآن فنحن غاضبون إذا حدث أي شيء
آخر ونحن في قمة
يقظتنا واستعدادنا وهذه
فكرة سيئة للغاية لأي شخص وخاصة كاه في
الشمال أن يعبث معنا الآن نحن كذلك  ليس
في نقطة ضعف في حياتنا نحن
في نقطة غضب من حياتنا لذلك أه
نتحدث عبر أه القنوات الأمريكية والأوروبية
نقول لها هذه فكرة رهيبة للعبث
معنا الآن ونحن نتحدث  إلى إيران
ونحن نقول لهم مرة أخرى من خلال أه
الأصدقاء سوف
نحاسبكم إذا حدث أي شيء في الشمال
لذلك أه نأمل أن نتمكن من تجنب
صراع آخر مع الحسبة مع
لبنان لذلك لشعب لبنان
وخاصة لبلح هذا  سيكون
العبث معنا الآن فكرة فظيعة ونحن
نحاول التأكد من أنهم
يفهمون ذلك